so my mom died when i was five she had
breast cancer
i was so aware of everything just
just hadn't had the words to describe it
[Music]
it makes you so tough because it's just
like when you lose your
primary caregiver and you're so young
and having to overcome that is the
hardest challenge when we're faced with
death i think that
it's like that veil kind of gets lifted
up and we feel fragile
you are faced with just sadness and
numbness and extortionate pain and
sometimes it feels like a living hell my
dad had been admitted to hospital
for what was thought to be a routine
operation
my aunt appeared she said albert
your daddy has just died and you have to
be the man of the house now
and look after your mummy and your
sister
my childhood ended it's almost like a
table
you know a leg of a table coming out and
so there has to be a kind of
readjustment as a 10 year old
i wanted to become a doctor to stop
other boys and girls mummies and daddies
dying
and that was the motivation the purpose
in my life
which has persisted until now
[Music]
he said to his private secretary have i
done enough
and his private sector sort of was taken
aback saying of course sir you know
look at what you've done world peace and
so on and he said no have i done enough
to make my father proud
it's called post-traumatic growth there
may be things that
children and young people take from it
a greater sense of maturity a different
sense of purpose
there's something about empathy somebody
who's been through an experience like
that
may be a better listener whether that
leads to leadership or not i don't know
one would like to think it might i think
the correlation between
a significant early loss like the death
of a parent
and leadership particularly successful
leaders
doing great things is probably to do
with passion
and drive wanting to make a difference
and somehow at some level wanting to
make
that person proud
[Music]
there's a disproportionate number of
children who end up in prison unemployed
etc so the downside can be simply
staggering
everybody's different but i mean what we
know about grief generally is that
it doesn't really go away there's been
different models of grief over the years
and have
kind of said that you know it starts off
overwhelming and slowly gets smaller and
smaller over time
and actually it's not really what we
found to be true
what seems to make a lot more sense is
this concept
of growing around your grief and
creating a bigger world so that you're
not suffocated by the grief
i had never ever been allowed to say
goodbye to my dad
and that image of him on my shoulder he
never knew i'd passed 11 plus he never
knew
i'd met a wonderful wife who's been with
me for 54 years
that regret is also very very powerful
people who've done quite a bit of work
on it and work on themselves and they've
found a way of making
sense of what happened to them and
they've
got this kind of growth mindset as it's
called
they can be fantastic leaders real
inspirations
that they have a kind of optimism
ironically
i'm such a happy optimistic person now
my identity and the things i like most
about myself are directly
from being bereaved when you reach a
point where you have accepted it
and reframed it into a more positive
narrative
you have gained so much
determination so much resilience
compared to that everything else is
is is nothing it's a walk in the park
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video